[Music]
in Undercover Boss News submitted by
beard is weird
a mayor disguises himself as a disabled
person to test his public sir oh that's
dope that's dumb you can't do that Amir
Amir it depends on which disability he
came self Oh what's the okay just
ability um well this one you guys got
laughed at quite a bit and I thought
that was [ __ ] up no we didn't like
that we loved it the fact that you had
to prove yourself cuz you're such a book
controlling you how to slam it against
leg syndrome and everyone makes fun of
me for that well that's awesome see
we're all see a lot of people after that
[ __ ] shame on you no one's laughing
loser
you think it's a joke until you sleep
with someone who is restless leg
syndrome and then you'll be crying home
to your mama or you watch a movie with
them yeah or sit next to them on a plane
movie theater do it
here's the world my god and they grab
your knee and you're like don't [ __ ]
touch me this is my release see you know
you take meds for that really good nerve
medications right now I've been doing it
but I'm trying to keep it up I'm so
grateful that knock out fast because if
we're in bed I just like every like 10
second sorry feel this oh I know movie
fear the worst really moving on my fake
you just know you don't even know you're
doing it I do know I'm doing it because
I want to control it so [ __ ] bad and
I'm like oh I don't know that I'm doing
it so this Mexican mayor disguised
himself as a disabled person put himself
in in a wheelchair so his name is called
me that's easy
people do that all day I cease acting
skills I want to I think it's gonna be
like Michael Scott so his name is Carlos
tena he's a mayor of Gotham milk which
isn't a [ __ ] guy Carlos hey all right
he looks like a cattle rancher yeah so
he dressed up like this
damn like you Gorsky
look he's so you wait - wait he's
weekend at Bernie's in this [ __ ] Blanc
is my crush
hold yeah I like this table they have a
blanket over their legs like [ __ ]
Roosevelt that is correct
yeah that was a great reference thank
you historical mm-hmm so he walked in so
for a long time he's been getting a lot
of complaints from the people saying
that his coworkers don't treat disabled
people very well which happens his truth
yeah and so he was like you know what I
got to find out for myself so he spent
two months putting together this to
shoot right
that's something you can find out
[ __ ] trash can agree what the [ __ ] is
this guy doing as mayor you find a
wheelchair two trash cans oh yeah laughs
about the Braille I used to sell medical
products and I happen to know that
they're fairly expensive
I highly doubt he dedicated every day he
was like doing mayor stuff for two
months and then last minute he was like
oh sure God do his dying time I'm an ER
I don't know but then why is he running
his own [ __ ] errands because well he
does have an assistant so they do
mention that he needs a newer system yes
that's it took two months to do this or
she's like I love my [ __ ] jobs like
it took me two months to get all this
[ __ ] for this matter than a blanket well
what if this dudes like hella particular
it's like the green beanie or the
[ __ ] navy blue nobody had to leave
this green blanket yeah get it to smell
uh sir
right I'd like to like let the Sun
bleach it yeah in the picture he looks
legit I think he did a great job he's a
master disguise old man he looked like
you would cough dirt in that picture
damn so and he wants it or like Roldan
he was seeking assistance at the social
I want to see if he disguises voices
[ __ ] oh no it's not my name is Samuel
follow so he asked for a free meal which
the disabled and poor citizens are
entitled to getting according to the law
he was ignored and even discriminated
against because he was saying like you
know people were passing by like his own
co-workers were passing by him and they
would like kick the chairs they were
just being window posted of me I
would've got out like [ __ ]
[ __ ] so then move on then he shows him
as mayor badge dude you gotta be hell
attempted to stab a badge no then he
ended up talking to like his secretary
and then she she was very rude to him
and told him to wait in the hallway but
yeah speak to the mayor which was
himself and then me so then you didn't
know now you know yeah just in case you
forgot his merit badge number
yeah so then he was just like he waited
enough time to see though you're like a
[ __ ] cat all right it was shiny in my
face all right so your tits are your
earrings don't you want for me just
focus on my worry does it you know cook
a potato jaw you do look like a cat
Kelsey thank you I've heard worse cats
are beautiful my cat's really pretty
it's what happens when you guys give me
caffeine's okay what were you saying so
he ended up waiting until you got enough
Oh like you know abuse and disrespect
I've seen the weights I got [ __ ] on
that's [ __ ] up but then nothing he
actually stood up and
unravel did he throw his poncho over
like that like his breaking point was
when someone kicked his wheelchair he
quit touching my food that's a long way
yeah delicious so then he that's when
the city hall staff [ __ ] their jaw on
the floor like yeah Delaney who was
about to pour hot coffee all over this
disabled person nose like yeah so he
says like you know the purpose of this
experiments to show the reality that
citizens experience every day and then
difference and neglect that they face
from public servants so he decided to do
this and but he actually did mention
that he wanted to do something similar
to this a while back but people just
forgot about it cuz his [ __ ]
assistant get [ __ ] up she takes two
months assistance operation took one day
wait a minute wait a minute didn't you
see that his own Oh is secretary not
assistant okay that would totally be me
because I'm forgetting everything right
now you're like oh [ __ ] sorry boss this
that [ __ ] hilarious dude yeah so what
what's changing because of this well so
it was viral I mean no it's like you he
told like he scolded everyone I gotta do
a bonus training where he scolded they
should be fired or they're kicking a guy
in a wheelchair
hey about about kicking people in
wheelchairs we don't like that here okay
not all of them displayed the same
attitude towards them but he made it
very clear that he did not want to hear
any more complaints from people being
mistreated again or he would take
drastic measures so he left it out a
little I'm going to work the next day
after you kicked your boss the mayor in
a [ __ ] wheelchair I just quit if I
was that person right this is like
Undercover Boss dude it's like and we're
sending some new rules about kicking
people the weird chairs but if you are a
boss and then someone one of your
employees kicked you in the wheelchair
right you own oh yeah you just look at
them every morning like Joe happy being
in a relationship with this man is the
scariest thing I can possibly imagine
if you [ __ ] up oh let's get them out of
here and I'm like I win I own you no one
can play you're like you're the lone
Congress yeah you'll do whatever Jill
wants whatever being a mayor is like
being like a king okay why are you so
judgy about it I'm just wondering what
happened to you that you didn't get
enough attention no it's just much
better when someone smarter controls
everything in that few obviously come on
like look at this situation you have
public servants kicking people in
wheelchairs right wouldn't it be better
if the almighty king that pretended he
was a wheelchair guy to fix this whole
problem he was able to just throw
everybody out change his whole
administration and do what he wants to
do you can have them all tied the pumps
and shot exactly there's a meet up the
streets to clean it up but you always
say yourself you can't stop there from
them from being bad people if we had a
dictator yeah but a good dictator this
does not see its time a good one like
keep Garth er like King Arthur and the
knights
yeah look at her they're good guys you
know like the Disney version he's very
well liked the Sunday morning cartoon
version okay fellas cool do you remember
that yeah I like that show a lot so I
mean like what's the difference dude
they call him a king and he's nice and
he was for good do you think anyone's
gonna trust this mayor anymore huh cool
I feel like some old lady's gonna be
walking down the hallway he's gonna rip
her wig off and then that guy gets sued
that's true that's a good point that's
how you keep something on their toes
they're paranoid yes these guys here's
what I don't think this helps actually I
think that now they'll just be looking
for this fat Mexican dude in a
wheelchair with sunglasses on and
they'll cater to him when he's there but
then everybody else it's like back to
normal Kane's point of the story check
your able miss y'all mmm-hmm yeah like
you know we don't have to think about
how I would get into a certain building
but people who don't have that able Ness
constantly like it turned them down from
places or they don't have the proper
like you keep it a bathroom think about
how many bathrooms are that are so tiny
or like in New York the bars are so tiny
like so many people who are disabled
don't get to experience the same life
with you now I moved to Las Vegas and
live in a hotel that's me Oh everything
is wheelchair accessible and I'll think
about that next time I'm in a very
narrow hallway I'll check my a bonus I
feel like casinos are the least casinos
are the least racist place ever like
they don't give a damn weren't they
built on like Native American land by
white dudes but there's also Native
American casinos
oh that's right and they kill it all
casinos I feel like they're the loot
they don't care cuz if you have money
you know you could do whatever you want
yeah so you're all welcome as long as
you're rich you could play poker in your
pajamas and those serve you [ __ ] prime
rib dinner at 3:00 a.m. oh that's crazy
it makes my dollars there's no better
place to live yep no casino hotel
[Music]
[Music]